what's going on guys Furious 7 the
seventh installment of The Fast and
Furious franchise is cruising into
theaters shortly we had the opportunity
to go and sit down with the cast
including the rock so of course we're
gonna send the Rock's best friend Nick
Mundy I'm not gonna lie
things get a little weird and a little
stupid check it out hey screen junkies
welcome to the fast hey screen junkies
it's Nick Mundy I'm at the Furious 7
junket as you can see all the badass
cars here I'm not nervous at this time I
know the other junkets haven't gone well
this is gonna go well I promise this is
huge for me I don't do interviews a lot
because I'm not good at them but uh I
got to go I'm just a huge fan of the
franchise I like yeah I get to shoot a
movie I could give you my number and
then we could just go up together like
do a matinee we could not use Java you
can tell me about what's coming up you
know ya know we can just hang out ruin
the whole thing
lunch will do a matinee welljust is
where you come in this is the part where
you shoot everything great thanks I saw
the movie last night and it might be one
of my favorite movies ever made like I'm
a huge fast in the Furious fan you're a
great musician - I mean Grammy nominee
acts like thank you I'm waiting for you
to do the theme song I actually wrote
some lyrics for you that like we can
pitch one day you know where you got to
go fast
got to get furious who's that man
looking so fly is that thérèse my my my
and then then you would do the chorus
and then it's not great I'm not a
Destiny's issue but uh
look thank you for having here good
meeting you man
yeah I'll appreciate take her cool I
work at screen junkies and everyone's
huge fancy we had them send in tweets
just like if you could use your Dom
Toretto voice should maybe do a couple
of different quotes I mean I mean Gabi
Moe but let me see you like a nerve to
the fella over there with the hella good
hair I'm just gonna shake to the fellow
over there with the really good hair I'm
just gonna shake look perfect if I could
get those baby group that bit yeah
okay I'll learn to meet the rock in two
minutes Yuri give me a head nod and a
hey man and a dick Sundy I'm really
worried it thinks my name is dick one
day when we first met I was like um
you're like biggest fan and then and
then we became best friends we are best
friends dude I thought that's alive
maybe we should get to know each other
and a good way to do that is playing
truth or dare we're family but play
truth or dare play truth or dare
okay all right haven't you want truth uh
yeah I want to okay who is your
celebrity crush is always Aldana
Scarlett Johansson and can you guess my
celebrity crush like you got a crush on
me and like it in a cool just like like
dude way not like weird way Oh what no
if I start throwing up and crying you'll
you'll hook me out would you have any
advice for the next new member of The
Fast and Furious say a husky gentleman
wants to join the gang um would you have
any advice
just be yourself because that
like the poster muscular dude mustard
cooler dude beautiful woman muscular
dude and then me just like with the
beard just like you know that's that big
good poster I think it is yeah I mean
why not here's a truth do you like me
more than a friend like a family way
like a Broadway yeah yeah absolutely
brothers worry we are brothers we're
family yes maybe maybe you can be my
best man at your wedding yeah uh what
when is it uh it's in September oh okay
yeah I could move it uh to when November
of the year yes
2018 okay have you ever thought about
like you think you could take Liam
Neeson like I got a list do you think
you think listen you're not supposed to
hit your old is all you yes what about
Batman
you gonna huh Batman anyone in a silly
cape can get it Ivan Drago from rocky
for Ivan Drago I know Dolph
yeah he's past his prime so he can get
it as you could break it
could you beat up yourself a duality of
man like type situation in a mirror
I always come on shop here's it there
would you mind lady and [ __ ] eaten uh
with me one of these things lady and
tramping mean we're both gonna eat at
the same time yeah forgot it like
friends do yes
yeah like those two scamp dogs does have
to be a banana to mean Kimmy just like
have we don't have spaghetti can we do
some like normal like lollipops or
something I think he's gonna do it I
mean would you don't look at me okay
yeah look a politician I would make it a
weird okay why I here we go now your
lips are quivering dude I'd like you
want to suck it yo what's up they didn't
suck it in them in the movie the dogs
were eating he did oh that's worse okay
all right here we go yeah uh-huh
bond we're gonna take your hand away
that's wrong yeah oh okay
no where are you doing it oh so where
are you going to go wedding Elgar oh
damn I got on your chin all right I'm
here I'm at the fast and furious junket
it's amazing and there's my boy right
here there's Nick Mundy
what's up Nick hey yo he specializes in
sucking bananas tell him you did too
okay don't tell man okay yeah so I
interviewed everyone I thought one
pretty good some better than the others
my stain got my shirt got stained when
the rock and the banana thing I'm sorry
Therese I think it what it went pretty
good did I hope it went well just thanks
for watching keep living your dreams you
know what everything was super fun but
that lady in the [ __ ] moment with the
banana and with you and the rock was a
little weird
no it wasn't that's what friends do
that's friends ladyandtramp a banana
well I'm looking forward to Furious 7
what about Furious 8 if they could bring
in any celebrity into the Fast & Furious
franchise who would it be
let us know in the comments section
below coolest answer we're gonna send
you a screen junkies t-shirt Nick you
have any thoughts the other wrong he's
already in it the rocks and me uh-uh and
you that I can get on board with
I want to thank Nick Mundy I want to
thank everybody from Fast and Furious
Furious 7
thanks for watching I'm how Rodney kept
me up on Twitter by established that you
need to be silent you need to be a boy
that you're stupid
then you sweat too much you should wear
the pins for your whole body and you
need to shut up
you just cut a promo on